the Joe Rogan experience no what are you
doing for thrills like do you have to
replace the Joe Rogan pocket do you have
to do something to replace well the
feeling of gambling or a void because
you're not gambling right that's an
excellent question no I can't I can't do
anything right because it escalates
right that's all right it escalates if I
put a $5 bet on a roulette table right
now by tomorrow morning I'd be running
guns to Cuba I'd have a
human-trafficking
everything the badness just gets worse
and worse because I can't have a beer
you know right right and that's hard to
that's hard to admit to yourself though
you know I mean I can't have one beer
and it took me a long time agree up that
concept some people can't so I've had
moments where you could have one beer in
your life have you ever gone what beats
I have a couple beers and that's it
yeah watching a game but the problem is
I mix vices I tell us that when I was a
longshoreman at the port in Newark okay
for a couple of years I was the orange
juice beer this happened twice
I had a bookie I used to gamble with so
drinking and coke and gambling does not
mix well that's why to give you free
drinks at a casino because you've you
know messed up yeah so I'm from Monday
Night Football the bookie took bets up
till eight o'clock kickoff was nine
o'clock so at 5:30 right after I got out
of work I would call the book and I
would say give me give me a thousand
dollars on the Giants play the Cowboys
give me a thousand other Giants then I
start drinking seven thirty comes around
I forget I made the bet two separate
times I bet on the other team at 7:30 I
called the book and I said give me the
Cowboys so all I could do is lose the
Vig so this happened twice
so the bookie bookies taped all your
calls and they destroy the tape at the
end before it kiss the cops get it but
what they do is they have the calls on
tape in case you have a like you have a
dispute I got a bet that he goes well I
got you on tape doing it so I said to
the bookie why did you let me do that he
goes cuz you gotta learn a life lesson I
go thanks mr. bookie for giving me a
life lesson you know I'm trying to win
money and he goes I got a tape for you
at 5:30
make it a bet so at 5:30 I'm like
articulate I go yeah give me the Giants
laying seven over the Cowboys give me
the under over forty one give me a dime
which is a thousand dollars just here's
you at 7:30 give me the [ __ ] Cowboys
I want the Cowboys in the other poor
line and you hear him try to go you just
bet the Giants flogged you know I didn't
I check on the phone
give him the GAO boys I'm a Cowboys I
met some girl who's a cowboy he took me
in uh so he's a bookies trying to give
me life coaching tip oh my god so so
what happens is if I would go have the
one beer on a Tuesday night in February
to sports bar then I realized Virginia
Tech is playing in a college basketball
game
I bet Virginia Tech then I have two
beers then I got coked and it's over so
your question is a great question what
do I do
what do you replacing it with that's
that's where this business which is
taking me back now I think eleven times
my 11th comeback
I have fans that I got that you know
through my TV and the Stern Show of
course that are so loyal stand up stand
up this dis business yeah doing what
we're doing right now toilet do another
funny guy who I love bullshitting
making money doing comedy I have a gig
tonight in Poughkeepsie I'm going to
Poughkeepsie you know and I'm gonna get
on stage and talk to people for an hour
and make a lot of money doing it he's
doing bananas no I'm doing a place go
laugh it up laugh it up in Poughkeepsie
so yeah I did the bananas thing a bunch
of times but so so you know that that
that's that's it that's what I'm
grabbing onto right now cuz women I've
lost three I say this all the time I
lost three fiancees because of heroin
heroin saved me a lot of money I dodged
three torpedoes with that the heroin was
way less expensive than a divorce so you
know right now I cling to my work
comedies the only thing that hasn't
abandoned me yes you know in a lot of
ways and you know there's businesses you
know that keeps taking me back you know
a lot of people are addicts they get
really addicted like marathon running
right have you ever thought of doing
some fun okay ooh it's like a crazy idea
but you if you could think you could run
a block let me can you run - yeah so you
know you run a mile
yeah actually no I'm gonna do a 5k well
I do I do a bit about this am i stand
the back one the first time I tried to
get off heroin just this um this trainer
who I hired this kid he said Minoo I
guarantee you a heroin high is not as
good as a running high and I said to him
have you ever tried heroin he goes no I
go well then you're not qualified to be
in this [ __ ] comedy cuz I've done
heroin and on occasion I've run and it's
not even close so anyway you get a
running huh you got to be in really good
shape and it's got a run more than 20
feet yeah why yeah I mean I mean do you
run is that would you yeah yeah I mean I
would love to get that kind of thing in
my life again I'm at way healthier than
I ever was in a long time
[Applause]